Nó này thì tôi lại rất mai mắn và vinh dự.
Thì được tham gia được tin về chuyến tham của một nè.
Đóng tâu quính sự nước ngoài,
tới các tiến xa thành phố ra nắng.
Và nhìn là cơ đang máy phần phần phần phần phía sau lưng tôi,
bởi vì được tượng là chiếc là phòng 1 đỏ.
Thì hạn là nhiều quý vị.
Đóng tâu để từ đâu rồi được, các bạn.
Có mắn tại các tiến xa từ sản ngày bởi lòng tháng 6.
Đi bắt đầu chuyến tham ngoại giao,
chiến hạn cho lớn thảo của hai quân hoàn gia,
các bạn có một chiến tham gia,
là tốt, mọi khảnh yên,
bởi khổ tiến chúc quân sự lâu sâu.
Đây là đầu chiến hạn nhẹ lớp Ha Li Fudge,
ra hơn một trong tham nè,
giọc gần tham nè mấy mẹ với tí đủ đoàn,
là khoảng 2 trong bụng người gọi.
Đóng tự thay là trên thân tâu,
khi ngoài,
giống trước tin,
các bạn tâu,
chá lâu thao,
thì ở phía bên này.
Có một biểu thử ở thêm,
nha, trước là phòng mô đó,
các bạn có thể đổi bắt tham.
Bỏ xong.
Để đối đoàn được giễn ra,
chẳng trong trọng này tại của mình câu gặp.
Bởi xe có mặt của phó đu đốc,
án gớst, họcsi,
tuy lại 2 quân hoàn gia,
xí quán triv y tổ, xá lâu thao,
có ngay đại xú, các bạn đã bị bình ảm.
Ví tuy lại 2 quân hoàn gia,
các bạn định trước bao giới.
Điều các bạn đã cử tổ,
cho lúc thao, thì cảm ơn hai chixt gái,
là mình chứng cho tập quán trọng.
Mặt các bạn đã sát định,
bởi vì việc vui chi dịch dịch dịch ở,
tổ giường, thải định giường,
và sát dự quán hệ chạm trẻ với các lối tát,
là việc như hải quân hệ dịch tham.
Vì tuy đoàn của tàu, cho phép chúng tôi,
thực hiện một chuyển tham làm.
Ôi sẽ đi, một cái a long shot,
để xem là hàng truyền.
Đi một vòng hói anh tổ,
nhé, sẽ đi,
hôm nay, chúng tôi sẽ vầy.
Cái em,
xoạn phải không?
Điều có thể thấy là khu bất gờ.
Sân chính ở trên tổ,
thì,
thường, để sân này,
nó rất thang.
Hôm nay,
nó sẽ chữa bảo dưỡng mà.
Sát yêu,
nó có tổ,
nó có tổ tham thì không sẽ liều có.
Điều có tổ,
nó có tổ,
nó có lúc thân sự rất là nhiều.
và phải hết sức cận thật với không ra nè
khi gì chưa thăm qua tàu?
Tâm hình thình tháng mọi sách lồn
nó được sảy
dùng người chức căng của nó là để chắc điện
và đi trên hả?
Tìm thằng bây giờ
thì em thấp tên lỗi hấp dụng gặp
lại này, cái này, nhìn này
có thể chắc điện
điểm rất quay cùng hoàn chính
1 xin bong trước tổ
tại đây có hệ thổng pháo hạng
nằm bệnh li cùng tổ hợp của khi hiện đại
tất nhiên là chúng tôi sẽ không được cũng cấp cấp thông tin kết thật chính tiết
nhưng buổi lại, đại diện thủy thủ đoàn
gián cho chúng tôi một cầu chuyện khá hành với bất qua ở trên hộng pháo
các phẩm có tên là thiệt thật mỏ vụ
đầu trang lúc thảo với mỗi chi tiết, đại diện trong một tiêu tổ thảnh điện chính thảo
ví dụ, như chiếc vương miệng là biểu tượng cho đội mỗi lạnh đạo và chỉ vì
còn như tiêu chớp là đại diện cho các thủy thủy thủy thủy hệng các nhậu của thánh
mặt kuyến lạnh mà người tìm mặt mạnh mắt mà mặt mỏ vệng cho kết thổng
trại của vực xện bong trước này, chúng tôi có thể quan sát được một số loại vụ khi của đầu
ngoài học pháo còn có hệ thổng phóng tin lượng, các loại sống
giữ gì đã giúp trá lúc thảo cho thảnh loại tồ chiến thức hiệp đa ra các nhậu vụ
tư dắt trên chống gầm, chống hạng đến phòng không
1 thăm quan của chúng tôi được phía và trong khoảng 2 chức phút.
2 chức phút này là 2 chức phút mà chúng ta thăm quan chuyện đó là bến ngoài thôi.
Súng được vào bên trong đó cũng là một điều.
Hết xe mình đường khi mà thăm ra các chuyện,
ngoại giao, trở thành hông của tờ quân sự như thế này.
Và trước khi một trở thành, sẽ còn kéo dài trong một vàng ai tới.
Bởi rất nhiều các bạn đông, liệt quan đến xa lưu tể thao, bỏng đà bỏng chuyện, giữa hải quân Việt Nam,
và các thành viên trong tuyệt của đoàn.
Cũng như các bạn đông, tình quyền, tưu thiện, các bạn đồng thăm lành trẻ.
Hết tật lành trẻ, bị chất đồng của nó khác.
Và rất mong là những người bạn đến từ các nơi ra xa xo được chúng ta sẽ có nhi trả nghiệp.
Thật là tiệt với chương nhiên ngày đó.